the thing that's shocking to me I don't
think a lot of people know this that
before friends came about Lorne Michaels
wanted you to be a part of the Saturday
Night Live cast like in a big way he saw
you as funny he did and you don't like
that when you were even at the School of
Performing Arts and you had acting
teachers and things and they'd say you
know what Jennifer you should think
about comedy you're very funny I wasn't
upset I just was thrown well you were
thrown because you said wait a second
I'm a [ __ ] serious actress yeah I'm
not a comedian right side it was
insulting to you a little bit I didn't
think you know check-off was funny right
I would have been like I'm going on
Saturday Night Live yeah I'm not gonna
go on friends what gave you the genuine
around at that point I don't think it
had come or it was just about to happen
right I was - I didn't think I would
like that environment and I remember
showing up and Sandler was there and
spade was there and I've known them or
I'd known them already a heavy like know
the Aniston's here oh how did you know
those guys uh I met them when I was like
20 21 after I done a television show
with a guy that knew them I find this
fascinating and who recommends you to
Lorne Michaels to go be on Saturday no
memory of how it happened but you went
for an audition
I just meant to talk with him well yeah
you see I think that I was such a young
twit I was like I think the women need
to be treated better here and I don't
did you like boys club yeah I you know
you're so you're just not the brightest
when you're in your early 20s you
lectured Lorne it lecture I was just
saying what I would hope if I was to do
this what I would what I would hope it
to be and did he look at you like just
hey who are you to talk he was like he
better calm down